today we're going to talk about the
eight important reasons why you should
start increasing more sauerkraut in your
diet sauerkraut is basically fermented
cabbage and it's combination between a
prebiotic fiber and a probiotic because
it has friendly bacteria so it can help
provide the fiber to microbes and it can
also give you friendly bacteria the only
time I wouldn't recommend taking
sauerkraut is if you had SIBO small
intestinal bacterial overgrowth because
you already have too much bacteria in
the small intestine when it should be in
the large and if you're adding more
fiber more food and more microbes into
your small intestine you're gonna feel
like a balloon because you're gonna get
a lot of gas so one way to know if you
have SIBO is if you consume something
like this and if you feel really bad
then you may have it if you feel really
good you probably don't have it number
one it will get rid of some of the anti
nutrients which are blocking the
absorption of a good nutrients and in
addition to that it enhances some of the
phyto nutrient availability number two
it can reduce gas production
some people get a lot of gas when they
consume raw cabbage but if they either
steam it cook it or ferment it they
won't have that gas because the
alteration in the carbohydrate number
three it will increase a compound called
acetylcholine which will help improve
your bowel movements increase digestive
juices and increase the pancreas release
of certain enzymes so it's generally
very good for digestion
number four increase in lactic acid this
is a very good thing pathogens
unfriendly microbes do not like acid
so this lactic acid will do nothing to
our good bacteria it just makes the
unfriendly bacteria want to go somewhere
else so it inhibits pathogens and by the
way lactic acid is also necessary to
help you absorb certain minerals okay so
that's one other benefit but it's mainly
an immune improving function alright
number five you can spike your vitamin C
content now out of all
the foods that are available sauerkraut
is at the top of the list certain types
of sauerkraut have about 700 milligrams
of vitamin C so the RDAs for vitamin c
are roughly between 70 and 90 milligrams
so it will give you ten times the amount
that your body needs so and vitamin C is
good for so many things
energy supporting the strength of the
artery wall and improving your immune
system in a major way alright number six
you can spike vitamin k2 now vitamin k2
helps tell calcium to go from the soft
tissues whether it's in your joints or
your arteries back into the bone so it
prevents the accumulation of calcium in
the wrong places
now typically vitamin k2 is in fatty
animal products and fatty dairy products
it isn't fermented soybeans as in NATO
but you can also get it from sauerkraut
now vitamin k2 has other benefits as
well it strengthens the mitochondria I
noticed I personally get more endurance
when I consume foods higher in k2 so
when I'm riding my bike I can go up
hills much better than when I don't
consume it alright number seven immune
support now we already talked about
lactic acid but sauerkraut does have
friendly bacteria as in a probiotic also
the fiber feeds the microbes that then
make certain compounds that help your
immune system that helps blood sugars
and it helps to feed the colon cells
themselves and 80% of your entire immune
system is located in your gut alright
last one number 8 it will spike vitamin
you now what is vitamin you it's
basically a chemical s methyl Matheny
this natural compound can improve
colitis ulcers inflammation of the gut
gastritis cabbage in general is just
really good for anything with the gut
now sometimes if you have an ulcer or a
severe inflammatory condition and you
take sauerkraut because there's acid in
that could actually irritate the stomach
and in which case you would probably
need something like just regular cabbage
in your salad or cole slaw but I found
that many people can do sauerkraut and
it really can help the inflammatory
process going in their gut all right
there you have it eight reasons why you
should consider consuming more
sauerkraut so if you want more knowledge
on how to create a healthy body
subscribe now and get daily
notifications